So with this effect but I haven given a name to yet but we're going to call time dilation.
You'll see why in a minute and we have these equations relating
the rates at which different clocks tick.
And actually this number v/c--I'm going to stop writing v/c.
Instead I'm going to use this number or variable β to represent the ratio of
a frame's speed to the speed of light and the variance are polishing things up,
let's go one step further and instead of writing t‘ like this, lets put the t out
and give this quantity in parenthesis its own name and the name I'm going to give--
well, we've seen the α and β, it's time for the next Greek letter, is γ.
So now, our complicated equation becomes t'=γt.
So actually we want to understand what's going on here. We need to understand γ a little better.
So first let me tell you without giving you much proof and I'm sorry for doing it
that v the speed that we can move or about a frame of reference can move--
well it has an upper bound--it can't go any faster than c, can't go faster than the speed of light.
So we can go with the slowest 0 stop or up to the speed of light
which means that β is between 0 and 1.
That can't be equal to the speed of light.
I want you to tell me what's the minimum and maximum value for γ.
So for γ min, it's the lowest possible value of γ as it is low as we want.
Can it go to a negative or billion--it's the lowest possible value 0 or is the lowest possible value 1.
Likewise, for γ max, it's the highest possible value that γ can be.
Is it 1, 2 or can γ max grow as large as we want.
So that's two questions. Select the best answer for each.